أنت تشهد عملاً شجاعًا من أعمال
التمرد، فتيات صغيرات تجمعن للتعلم
في فصل دراسي سري لطالبان،
إنهم مجرمات يتحدين الحظر المفروض على
تعليم الإناث، لكن هؤلاء الطالبات يقولن
إنهن مصممات على مواصلة
تعليمهن بغض النظر عن التكلفة، كما أخبرنا اثنان منهم.
لماذا قلت لنفسي إنه حتى لو
اعتقلتني حركة طالبان فسوف أقف
وأخبرهم أنني لا أريد أن أبقى في
المنزل، وتقول إنني أريد فقط أن أتعلم
وهذه ليست
جريمة، وقد مُنحت شبكة CNN حق الوصول إلى هذا
المكان السري  الفصل الدراسي بشرط
إخفاء هوية الطلاب
والموظفين وإبقاء الموقع
مخفيًا، لكن السماح لكاميراتنا بالدخول يأتي في خطر غير عادي حيث
يتجمع حوالي 30 طالبًا في هذه
الغرفة الصغيرة لتعلم كل شيء من
العلوم إلى الرياضيات إلى الخياطة
والرسم، وهي وسيلة ليست حقيقية  اسمها هو
معلمتهم، الخوف معنا في كل ثانية نحن
داخل المدرسة، كما تقول، ولكن هناك
قوة أقوى من الخوف. أملنا في
المستقبل، هذه واحدة من تسع
مدارس سرية تقوم بتعليم أكثر من 400 فتاة
عبر ثماني مقاطعات أفغانية،
وتديرها  شبكة سرية تسمى
عائلات ساراك تجد البرنامج من خلال
الكلام الشفهي ويتزايد الطلب عليه.
أسسته هذه المرأة
بيستو حكيم، كما تقول بسبب
نشاطها. لقد أُجبرت مؤخرًا على الفرار من
أفغانستان ولكن في صيف عام 2021 عندما
سقطت كابيل في أيدي طالبان  تخبرنا
أنها توقعت حظر
تعليم الإناث وذهبت إلى العمل لذلك كنا
نشاهد بعض الأفلام الوثائقية كنت
أنظر إلى امرأة أفغانية تجلس أه فوق
NGS في أماكن مخفية وتحت الأرض
مستوحاة جزئيًا من كريستيان ومن قبل
199 6 سي إن إن معركة وثائقية من أجل
أفغانستان بدأت حكيم  لكي أحذو
حذو النساء منذ ما يقرب من 25 عامًا،
أحب عملي، إنه حقي في العمل وأحتاج
إلى العمل، أفغانستان
محطمة تمامًا، إنها في الظلام، طالبان
تجبر النساء على هذا الظلام، مما يؤدي إلى
محوها فعليًا من الكثير من
الحياة العامة.  تقول الأمم المتحدة إن
القواعد الصارمة التي تطبقها المجموعة قد ترقى إلى الفصل بين الجنسين
وجرائم ضد
الإنسانية، لكن هذا الفصل الدراسي الصغير في
الظل يوفر بصيص من
الأمل، فالمدرسة بمثابة نور بالنسبة لي،
وتقول إنها بمثابة طريق بالنسبة لي
يمكنني من خلاله رؤية السعادة و  شروق الشمس في نهايتها
هو أيضًا شريان حياة، فقد زادت معدلات
زواج الأطفال وعمالة القاصرين وحالات
الانتحار المبلغ عنها منذ
حظر تعليم الإناث وفقًا
للأمم المتحدة، ويعاني عدد لا يحصى من الفتيات المحصورات في
منازلهن من
القلق والاكتئاب وكانت فاطمة من
بينهن.  شعرت وكأنها سجينة،
تقول إنها مثل السجين الذي يُسمح له فقط
بتناول الطعام والشراب ولكن لا يُسمح له
بفعل أي شيء
آخر بدعم من عائلتها،
اكتشفت المدرسة ووجدت
شغفها، فهي تريد أن تصبح مصممة أزياء مشهورة.
أريد أن يكون مستقبلي مشرقًا، تقول
إنني لا أريد أن أكون خلف
قناع إلى الأبد، أريد أن أكون قادرًا على إظهار
وجهي الحقيقي، نساء وفتيات شجاعات
يحلمن بمستقبل بدون طالبان
ويستعدن بجرأة للخروج إلى
العالم.  الضوء مرة أخرى سال عبد العزيز سي إن إن
لندن